[Musik]
wenn unsere Welt eine andere ist dann
muss auch unsere Politik eine andere
sein
die Welt ist in Aufruhr aus den Angeln
gehoben durch einen einzigen Mann
Regierung und Opposition werden nicht
müde zu betonen es ist putinskrieg
entgegen all seinen Beteuerungen führt
er seit Donnerstagmorgen einen
Angriffskrieg mitten in Europa Putin
stellt damit alles in Frage worauf sich
die zivilisierte Welt nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg geeinigt hat Bundeskanzler
Scholz spricht von einer Zeitenwende die
Welt werde nicht mehr so sein wie vorher
was aber bedeutet das für uns in
Deutschland für Europa und für die ganze
Welt startet jetzt ein neues Wettrüsten
und welche Opfer sind wir bereit für
Frieden in Europa für Freiheit und für
Demokratie zu bringen darüber will ich
diskutieren jetzt in Unter den Linden
und das sind meine Gäste Gesine lötz
stellvertretender Chefin der
Linksfraktion im Deutschen Bundestag und
Jürgen Trittin guten Abend
außenpolitischer Sprecher der
Bundestagsfraktion der Grünen in Bayern
ein herzliches Willkommen hier im Studio
Herr Trittin ein Angriffskrieg mitten in
Europa
konnten sie sich das letzter Woche bis
letzte Woche Donnerstag überhaupt
vorstellen
wir haben ja eben vielleicht etwas
kritischer auf putinen geschaut als
andere in deutschen Bundestag aber auch
ich habe nicht damit gerechnet dass er
flächendeckend die Ukraine überfällt mit
dem Ziel die dort gewählte Regierung
abzusetzen und wegzuputschen ich ging
davon aus dass wenn er militärisch nach
der Anerkennung vorgeht möglicherweise
nach dem Modell Georgien also
südostizien ab Asien den Don Bass
sozusagen arrondiert und für sich nimmt
das wäre auch eine Verletzung der
territorialen Integrität gewinnen aber
dieses Ausmaß dort vorzugehen dass habe
ich in der Tat nicht für wahrscheinlich
gehalten er hat uns alle im schlechten
überrascht heute gab es dann ja
Friedensgespräche zwischen der
ukrainischen und der russischen Seite
ist das eine Nebelkerze von Putin oder
ist das vielleicht tatsächlich so etwas
wie in Hoffnung
sie ist immer gut wenn man miteinander
redet die Ausgangsbedingungen beider
Seiten sind aber so dass die andere
Seite sie zurzeit noch nicht annehmen
kann insofern ist die einzig gute
Nachricht dieses Tages dass man gesagt
hat dass man sich ein paar Tagen wieder
treffen will
ich sehe dieses Angebot jetzt doch zu
sprechen obwohl die Ukraine ihre
Widerstandshandlung aus sichtputins
nicht beendet hat unter anderem daran
begründet dass Putin im eigenen Land
offensichtlich Probleme hat er hat sich
offensichtlich ein Stück für kalkuliert
was die Dauer der Operation angeht er
hat wohl dieser Form des Widerstandes
nicht gerechnet und er muss erleben dass
jetzt 950.000 Menschen eine Petition
unterschrieben haben beenden Sie diesen
Krieg das bestimmte
systemnahe Oligarchen anfangen zu sagen
das geht so nicht also alles Dinge die
er glaube ich in dieser Form nicht auf
dem Zettel hat inwiefern er sich
verkalkuliert hat und auch die
Opposition im eigen Land unterschätzt
hat darauf wollen wir gleich auch noch
zu sprechen kann frau Lötsch die Linke
bezeichnet sich ja als eine
pazifistische Partei wie groß ist jetzt
ihr Schock zumal ja auch der Angriff
oder die Aktion ganz eindeutig von
russischer Seite kommt also wir sind
natürlich schockiert dass überhaupt so
in unserer Nähe ein Krieg geführt wird
aber zur Wahrheit gehört leider auch das
ja überall auf der Welt Kriege geführt
werden und es ist plötzlich ganz nah
dran und wir wissen dass wir selber sehr
gefährdet sind und darum müssen wir
alles tun und alles verhindern dass du
zu führen könnte dass es wirklich einen
großen Weltenbrand gibt allerdings hat
Putin ja hat Trittin hat das ja
angesprochen an einigen Beispielen schon
lange Krieg geführt das war aber
meistens weiter weg also ich kann mich
zum Beispiel entsinnen dass wir im Jahr
2004 im Deutschen Bundestag über den
Tschetschenien Krieg diskutiert haben
sicher auch mit Leidenschaft und ich
habe damals für die PDS noch die Linke
gab es ja noch nicht sehr scharf Putin
kritisiert aber es war ein Krieg der
allen sehr weit weg Schienen und ist
jetzt der große Unterschied mir scheint
es auch noch mehrere Unterschiede zu
geben wenn man sich das mal vor Augen
führt was in den letzten Tagen passiert
ist Putin spricht der Ukraine das
Existenzrecht ab er spricht von einer
runter von Nazis und Drogensüchtigen im
Kiew und von einem Genozid in der
Ostukraine die eigene Frieden oder die
eigene Aggression hinter
Friedensmissionen was macht das mit
ihrem Bild von Russland wenn sie sich
das jetzt so im Zeitraffer vor Augen
führen putin ist der nicht Russland die
russischen Menschen werden ja in diesem
Krieg missbraucht Herr Trittin hat ja
auch schon angesprochen dass es jetzt
eine große Petition gibt und es gibt
auch Proteste und die Proteste sind ja
nicht ungefährlich für die Menschen und
wenn wir uns auch die Bilder ansehen der
Soldaten die sind ja teilweise blutjung
die sind 16 die sind 18 die haben ihr
ganzes Leben vor sich und wenn Sie in
diesem Krieg nicht getötet oder verletzt
werden sind sie für ihr Leben
traumatisiert und jede Mutter die ihren
Sohn in den Krieg ziehen lässt die ist
ja völlig verzweifelt und darum denke
ich müssen oder auch einen klaren
Unterschied machen Putin als Adresse als
Autokrat als jemand der wirklich den
Weltfrieden aufs Spiel setzt dann müssen
wir auch die Frage stellen wie ist es
überhaupt dazu gekommen wir haben ja
2001 im Deutschen Bundestag da war ich
noch nicht Mitglied aber ich habe das
nachgelesen Putin erlebt mit einer Rede
die von allen Fraktionen bejubelt wurde
aber leider ist daraus augenscheinlich
nicht genügend gekommen also wichtig
finde ich und das ist ja in allen
Kriegen so dass man wirklich
unterscheidet zwischen den Menschen dem
Volk was darunter leidet und das Volk
leidet in der Ukraine aber natürlich
auch die Menschen in Russland
insbesondere die Familien die Soldaten
hinschicken müssen und natürlich die die
jetzt gegen Putin protestieren und
verhaftet und gequält werden das ist
ganz furchtbar die Rede von Putin die
sie erwähnt haben kann man auch in der
Mediathek von Phoenix noch einmal
nachschauen sie haben jetzt einen
Unterschied gemacht zwischen Putin und
Russland ich möchte trotzdem noch mal
nachhaken inwiefern hat sich ihr Bild
von der russischen verändert also
wir haben keine Illusionen gehabt über
Putin es gab sich ja unterschiedliche
Einschätzungen wie in allen Parteien und
auch unter allen Experten wie weit
ergehen würde aber Putin hat sich ja
schon sehr lange sehr klar dagegen
geäußert dass er irgendetwas mit der
Sowjetunion zu tun hat das hat er jetzt
in der großen Rede die er gehalten hat
zum Kriegseintritt anders kann man es ja
nicht sagen zum Angriff noch mal ganz
deutlich gemacht er hat quasi Lenin in
der Rede dafür verantwortlich gemacht
dass die Ukraine ein selbstständiger
Staat ist und er hat gesagt er will dort
den Kommunismus ausrotten vielleicht gab
es noch ein den ein oder anderen der
gedacht hat Putin ist so etwas wie ein
Vertreter der Sowjetunion aber der ist
spätestens seit dieser Rede eines
Besseren belehrt auch darauf wollen wir
noch zu sprechen kommen Herr Trittin
putinskrieg hat die Welt ja nicht nur in
angstversetzt sondern auch so eine Art
Schockstarre ausgelöst ist jetzt
eigentlich paar Tage nach diesem
Angriffskrieg oder dem Beginn dieses
Angriffskrieg schon komplett gelöst was
ich sehe ist dass weltweit
ist klare Positionierung gibt wenn ich
die Debatte heute in der
UN-Generalversammlung soweit ich sie
verfolgen konnte gesehen habe ist das
auch keine Frage des systemwettbewerbs
sondern diese Aggression gegen die
Souveränität eines Landes die Rückkehr
eines eroberungskrieges das ausgerechnet
am Land gegenüber was nach dem dort oder
durch den deutschen Überfall auf dieser
werteunion 8 Millionen Menschen leben
verloren hat und das jetzt durch das
manchmal so zu sagen im Verständnis
vieler Bruder Erfolg was auch unter
dieser faschistischen Überfall damals
gelitten hat und Millionen Tote zu
beklagen hatte dass das zurückkehrt nach
Europa das ist glaube ich etwas was sehr
sehr breit
zurückgewiesen wird und ich stelle fest
dass auch Staaten die oft eine Media sag
mal oszillierende oder amigurität
solchen Systemen haben an dieser Stelle
sagen wir machen jetzt mit
beispielsweise bei der Isolierung
Russlands von bestimmten Finanzmärkten
Singapur hat das heute beschlossen
selbst die Schweiz bekannt für als Hort
von Schwarzgeld und Geldwäsche hat sich
diesen Überlegungen angeschlossen also
ich sehe schon dass jenseits
der vielen Menschen die auf die Straße
gehen 500.000 Menschen am Sonntag hier
in Berlin heute beim Rosenmontag 250
Menschen 1000 Menschen in Köln die für
Frieden demonstriert haben statt ihres
Geliebten Karnevals an dieser Stelle
das ist also neben der Zivilgesellschaft
eben auch Handlungen gibt die diese
Aggression wirklich in die Grenzen
weisen sie sprachen von den
oszillierenden Staaten gerade kam eine
Meldung über ein Ticker das Ungarn jetzt
aber verwehrt das Kriegsmaterial durch
das Territorium also durch das durch den
ungarischen Staat geliefert werden soll
ist das nicht schon wieder ein Beginn
des oszillierens
Ungarn und Viktor Orban Lieblings Gast
bei der CSU auf
x-sommerklausuren hat eine unverhohlene
Sympathie für das Post sowjetische die
Stimme ihnen ja zu dass das ganz wenig
mit dieser werteunion zu tun hat dieser
werteunion hat die Schlussakte von
Helsinki mitverhandelt unterschrieben
und ratifiziert die verletzt Putin
gerade also man muss ja dieser Wertung
fast hochhalten gegenüber diesem
Russland da muss sie nur fast hochhalten
aber hier sehen wir eine Entwicklung die
man mit sorgen erfüllen muss ich muss
Ihnen sagen ich war eher überrascht dass
in den wenigen Stunden die am Ende
geblieben sind und mein wirksames
Sanktionspaket zu verhängen am Ende
Ungarn mit dabei gewesen ist insofern
ist das jetzt der Rückfall in die alten
Unsinn
die Situation in der Ukraine ist alles
was man jetzt hört sehr bitter im Moment
die Ukraine wehrt sich gegen einen
übermächtigen Gegner in Deutschland
früher helfen müssen
die Ukraine ist eines der ärmsten Länder
der Welt von 190 ist es auf Platz 139
und das zeigt natürlich schon dass auch
die Situation der Menschen da sehr
kompliziert und sehr schlecht ist und
wir hätten glaube ich auch die Menschen
dort viel besser unterstützt wenn wir
spätestens seit dem EU also zu ihren
Abkommen aus dem Jahre 2014 dort viel
mehr auch Wirtschaftshilfe geleistet
hätten die auch direkt bei den Menschen
ankommt die Ukraine ist auch ein Land wo
die sozialen Unterschiede sehr groß sind
und wie gesagt die Armut ist dort
besonders hoch in der
Pro-Kopf-Einkommen ist liegt noch hinter
dem von Yellow raus und darum glaube ich
dass wir auch sehr mit uns selber in die
Kritik gehen müssen wie konnte die
Situation dort so schlecht werden wobei
zwei Milliarden die von Deutschland in
der Ukraine gegangen sind jetzt auch
kein plattenspiel ist ja aber die Frage
ist natürlich die wir uns ja alle
stellen wenn die Menschen dort zu arm
sind sind sie dort wirklich angekommen
wo sie auch ankommen sollten es gibt
darüber haben wir auch im Bundestag in
einer Sondersitzung eines Ausschusses
Zuschusses für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit diskutiert
was passiert jetzt mit den Projekten der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit waren sie
wirkungsvoll und viele Menschen hoffen
ja darauf dass sie weitergehen aber das
ist natürlich auch eine Frage die zu
entscheiden ist und ich hoffe dass wir
alles tun können dass dort ein
Waffenstillstand erreicht wird dass die
Waffen niedergelegt werden und dass die
Gespräche die heute begonnen haben
fortgesetzt werden und zwar sofort
gesetzt werden dass es wirklich
Menschenleben rettet ich bin ja bei der
Hoffnung dabei aber ich finde man muss
schon dazu sagen dass die mangelhafte
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
wesentlich verursacht worden ist durch
die andauernde kriegerische Intervention
in der Ostukraine die dazu geführt hat
wesentliche Teile des Staatshaushaltes
zu binden die im übrigen auch viele
Bemühungen die es gegeben hat seitens
der Europäischen Union nicht nur Geld zu
geben also die Deutschen als die größten
Gebers die eine Geschichte aber man hat
auch versucht durch entwickeln der
Korruption vorzubeugen dieser
Umverteilung von der normalen
Bevölkerung und die Taschen von sehr
wenigen Oligarchen einen Riegel
vorzuschieben das ist immer wieder
durchbrochen worden durch diesen
kriegsdiskurs innerhalb der der Ukraine
und insofern haben wir es hier mit einer
Mischung zu tun nämlich der Entscheidung
die die Menschen in der Ukraine
getroffen haben mit dem Aufstand auf dem
Maidan die war ja begründet wir wollen
Teil Europas werden wir wollen es mit
der EU assoziieren das war erstmal eine
Entscheidung die war ganz im Bereich der
Zivil der Wirtschaftspolitik und solcher
Fragen und darauf ist die militärische
Antwort von Putin gekommen Annektion der
Krim dauerhafter Krieg hybrider Krieg
oder wie immer man das nennen will Proxy
war in der Ostukraine und das hat
natürlich erheblich dazu beigetragen
dass dieses Land sich allerhilfe zum
Trotz nicht entwickeln kommt verliert
jetzt ging es aber vor allem ja auch um
die aktuelle Hilfe die sich die Ukraine
gerne gewünscht hätte also jetzt in der
aktuellen Situation jetzt Deutschland
helfen müssen spätestens seit
Donnerstagmorgen die Frage ist natürlich
immer was man unter Hilfe versteht und
welche Hilfe auch wirkungsvoll ist und
was jetzt am Wochenende am Sonntag von
Bundeskanzler Scholz vorgetragen wurde
das war zumindest mein Eindruck hat auch
große Teile der Koalitionen überrascht
also zumindest direkt neben uns sitzen
ja die Abgeordneten der SPD und als
Scholz gesagt hat er will das
Grundgesetz ändern und er will ein
Sondervermögen Rüstung oder Bundeswehr
Schaffen von 100 Milliarden er hat jetzt
einen Vertrag unterzeichnet über
bewaffnete drohen da hat übrigens nur
die Union geklatscht die anderen
Parteien haben dann nicht geklatscht ist
die große Frage ist die ankoplung des
rüstens des Wettrüstens ein wirklicher
Beitrag der Ukraine zu helfen oder wäre
nicht unsere Aufgabe als Bundesrepublik
Deutschland vor allen Dingen dafür zu
sorgen dass es friedlich wird und auch
in unserem eigenen Interesse muss man
sagen wir sitzen ja hier mitten in
Europa und darum haben wir auch glaube
ich so viele Menschen so viel Angst weil
sie wissen es könnte sie auch selbst
betreffen also die Hilfe muss humanitär
sein wir bereiten uns ja auch also
zumindest in Berlin aber in allen
anderen Bundesländern bereiten wir uns
ja auch vor auf die Aufnahme von
kriegsvertriebenen die ersten sind ja
auch schon angekommen und das muss
natürlich auch so geschehen dass es auch
in einer würdigen Form geschieht und
nicht in nur in Form von Sonntagsreden
Herr Trittin Deutschland hat lange
gezögert mit Sanktionen auf der einen
Seite da sind noch Stream 2 und Swift
Stichworte aber auch mit
Waffenlieferungen aus ihrer Sicht kommt
das jetzt alles zu spät
ich kann diesen Eindruck nicht ganz
teilen Deutschland hat sehr lange darauf
gesetzt die Ukraine die Russen davon
abzuhalten zu intervenieren indem wir
sie versucht haben auf dem Feld der
ökonomischen und politischen Sanktionen
abzuschrecken es hat andere Verbündete
der Ukrainer Verbündete auch
Deutschlands gegeben die geglaubt haben
dass Abschreckung funktioniere wenn man
in dieses systemwaffen reinliefert jetzt
müssen beide sich in die Augen gucken
und feststellen die Abschreckung sowohl
im deutschen Weg wie im vielleicht
niederländischen Weg hat nicht
funktioniert es hat nicht gehindert
Russland dort reinzugehen wir haben bis
zum Schluss zum Beispiel daran
festgehalten anders als andere auch
andere Nato-Partner die
Beobachtermission der OSZE
aufrechtzuerhalten erst als gar nichts
mehr ging haben wir sie abgezogen wir
haben noch letzt Anfang letzter Woche
darüber debattiert
die abgezogenen Amerikaner teilweise zu
ersetzen ich glaube dass man uns nicht
vorher helfen kann wir werden
irgendjemand im Stich gelassen und dass
wir nicht alle Mittel auch und gerade
die es im zivilen Bereich gibt
ausgetestet haben und Putin hat das
alles beiseite gewischt auch die Ansätze
einer militärischen Abschreckung und
jetzt ist man in einer Situation wo wir
in der Tat großen Aufwand betreiben
müssen um die Menschen
zu sichern die aus der Ukraine geflohen
sind der UN spricht von zwischen einer
halben Millionen Menschen die raus sind
die müssen solidarisch aufgenommen
werden ich sehe in den Städten und
Gemeinden Deutschlands viele Menschen
die das tun und wir müssen uns der Frage
stellen ob in dieser Situation ein Land
was nach Artikel 51
der un-kater das Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung hat und angesichts
auch eines blockierten Sicherheitsrates
ist fast wörtlich aus der un-karte
entnommen
angesichts eines blockierten
Sicherheitsrats aufgrund des Tinnitus
Russlands nicht das Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung hat und da haben wir
entschieden er hat es und wir werden
dieses Recht auf selbstverteidigen
müssen was anderes als Abschreckung auch
durchlieferung von Waffen unterstützen
wie lautet jetzt die Antwort auf die
Frage ob es zu spät kommt
ich glaube dass wir mit der Abschreckung
gescheitert sind das ist glaube ich das
Eingeständnis was sich alle alle
Europäer machen müssen an dieser Stelle
die Maßnahmen die man jetzt macht also
die die Wirtschaftssanktionen und die
Waffenlieferung zu spät ja oder nein
nein ich glaube das ist richtig ist
solange man verhandelt das war ja die
Grundidee zu sagen solange man im
Gespräch mit Putin ist du kriegst eine
harte Antwort wenn du dich auf den Weg
der Gewalt begibst und er hat sich auf
den Weg der Gewalt begeben und er kriegt
jetzt eine harte Antwort übrigens die
härteste Antwort dies gibt es das
Einfrieren der zentralbankvermögen
Russlands es ist viel härter als alles
was wir bei Swift diskutiert haben das
war übrigens schon beschlossen
in ihrer Partei gibt es ja durchaus
unterschiedliche Sichtweisen oder gab es
bis zum Donnerstag unterschiedliche
Sichtweisen die man mit Russland umgehen
sollen jedenfalls ist das meine
Beobachtung da gab es die eine Fraktion
die doch eher Verständnis für die
russische Position
hat erkennen lassen und andere wiederum
die schon schneller zu erkennen gegeben
haben dass man in Russland und in Putin
den Aggressor sieht wie sehen Sie das
persönlich also ich glaube es gibt in
allen Parteien im Augenblick ja sehr
heftige Diskussionen hat man die Lage
richtig eingeschätzt und was kann man
jetzt machen also ich glaube wir müssen
analysieren welches Szenarien ist jetzt
gibt also wenn die das Hauptszenario ist
Waffenlieferung dann ist die große
Gefahr dass es ein Afghanistan 20 gibt
und dann ist auch die große Gefahr dass
daraus der dritte Weltkrieg entsteht ich
glaube sie haben das auch schon gesagt
Herr Trittin in einem Interview und dann
ein Szenario besteht ja darin dass
Russland sich völlig quasi abwendet und
sagt also von Europa können wir nichts
erwarten wir verbünden uns nur mit China
und Indien und wir haben jetzt in den
Diskussionen in Sicherheitsrat und so
weiter schon gesehen dass es ja da auch
zumindest von Seiten Chinas eine gewisse
Offenheit gibt
und das dritte Szenario ist
putin wird weggeputscht wird ersetzt
durch jemanden der aber dann die gleiche
Frage stellt wie ist die Stellung in der
Welt und ich glaube wenn wir noch mal
zurückschauen die zeitenwände die ist
nicht heute die war eigentlich schon
1990 mit der Neuaufteilung der Welt es
gibt geht ja immer um
wirtschaftseinfluss Szenarien und wenn
man die viele ja gemacht haben jemanden
wie Putin nicht ernst nimmt ich würde
nicht sagen ich unterschätzt man fühlte
sich eben immer überlegen und die NATO
dachte wir haben alles im Griff und so
ist es ja nicht gekommen und dieses
nicht ernst genommen werden dieses
vielleicht auch unterschätzt werden das
Recht sich jetzt und wir aber die
einzige Möglichkeit die wir haben ist ja
eine ein Weltfrieden zu sichern um
überhaupt unser aller Überleben zu
sichern in einer Situation wo wir
umgeben sind von Atommächten die Frage
ist ja wie geht man jetzt weiter sie
haben es im Prinzip auch schon so ein
bisschen angesprochen offensichtlich hat
man ja Putin und auch sein seinen Willen
mit seinem Hoch großmachtsgelüsten
wirklich die Welt in Angst und Schrecken
zu versetzen da hat man ihn offenbar
unterschätzt und sie das nicht wieder
wenn Sie das genauso argumentieren
gerade nein in ganzem Gegenteil ich
unterschätze ihn überhaupt nicht und
darum sage ich wir müssen schauen wie
kann man auf dem Verhandlungswege dafür
sorgen dass natürlich mit allen
Sanktionen sind ja auch schon diskutiert
worden dass er ich sag mal einsieht ist
vielleicht so ein Wort was hier gar
nicht so richtig passend ist aber dass
er sagt wir müssen die Waffen
niederlegen wir brauchen eine Waffenruhe
wir brauchen Frieden und natürlich muss
allen Seiten auch der Ukraine gesagt
wenn ihr kann ihr seid keine Pufferzone
zwischen der Nato und Russland sondern
wir als Europäische Union natürlich auch
wir sind ja deutsche Abgeordnete wir als
Vertreter des der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland wir respektieren eure
Interessen und wir werden euch niemals
zu einer Pufferzone zwischen zwei
Systemen degradieren aber wenn ich das
noch mal sagen darf
ich bin ja sehr für Verhandlung ich
glaube wir können uns nicht vorwerfen
lassen als als auch als jetzige
Bundesregierung dass wir nicht sehr viel
versucht hätten mit Putin zu verhandeln
das was ich jetzt erlebe ist wer bringt
ihn eigentlich dazu ernsthaft zu
verhandeln
und das Können meines Erachtens nur zwei
Elemente sein das eine ist dass er das
was er übrigens sehr teilweise
Video Nachrichten also in
Internetportalen schon publiziert hatte
da erschienen in Russland nach drei
Tagen die berüchte Kiew ist erobert es
mussten sie denn zurücknehmen weil das
nicht eingetreten ist warum ist der
jetzt dabei zu sagen ich möchte noch mal
sprechen weil offensichtlich er
gezwungen ist zu verhandeln weil sein
ursprünglicher Plan nicht aufgegangen
ist das wäre ein Argument so schwer mir
das Feld an dieser Stelle zu sagen die
Widerstandsfähigkeit auch militärisch
der Ukraine ein Stück zu stärken damit
es überhaupt zu Verhandlung kommt es
gibt ein zweites Element was ich fast
höher als das militärische einschätze
es ist nämlich für Russland keine
attraktive Perspektive
nur noch mit Indien und mit dem Respekt
Alm Respekt vor dem chinesischen Markt
mit China verhandelt zu dürfen Russland
nicht nur die Bevölkerung richtig auch
die gesamte Wirtschaft ist existenziell
auf funktionierende Beziehung auch nach
Europa angewiesen sie haben erlebt was
passiert ist nach der
Annektion der krimen als sie die
Pipeline nach China gebaut haben sie
haben wenig Arbeitsplätze gekriegt weil
die Chinesen sie gebaut haben und
anschließend haben die Chinesen ihn
einen Preis diktiert der nach deutlich
unter dem den sie in Europa erzielt
haben das heißt sie stehen eigentlich
vor der Wahl entweder zu einem Anhängsel
Chinas zu werden und dass das Gegenteil
eines selbstbewussten Russlands oder
ihre Beziehung zu Europa zu haben und
diese beiden Punkte stark zu machen das
ist das was wir haben und deswegen
glauben wir dass wir nur auf diesem Wege
in eine Verhandlungssituation wieder
reinkommen ich glaube übrigens nicht
dass wir kurzfristig
so lights mir tut ein Dream change in
Russland erleben werden
wir sind jetzt schon wieder eigentlich
dabei Putin bei dem Versuch Putin
einzuschätzen und zu überlegen was macht
er wenn ich kann mich ganz gut erinnern
wir saßen glaube ich im Dezember hier
und da gab es dieses Argumente auch
schon dass Putin damit rechnen muss zum
Anhängsel von China zu werden das hat
ihn aber auch nicht davon abgehalten
jetzt die Ukraine in einem einmaligen
Vorgang zu überfallen ich glaube er
hatte zwei Sachen nicht auf der Rechnung
das eine war in der Tat der Widerstand
in der Ukraine und auf der anderen Seite
die Einheitlichkeit der Reaktion die
jetzt abgestimmt zwischen Europa und den
USA und vielen asiatischen Staaten auf
diese Geschichte erfolgt ist das ist für
Russland
die haben 630 Milliarden 630 Milliarden
sind zwei bundeshaushalte sie sind immer
so inzwischen anderthalb würde ich sagen
aber in dieser Größenordnung da kommt
der zum Zeit nicht ran
das heißt seine Reserve die er sich
gebildet hat um tatsächlich an dieser
Stelle eine wirtschaftssanktion länger
zu überstehen ist zur Zeit blockiert
das wird keine einfache Situation und
das ist der Grund warum auch jetzt in
der Elite bei denen die im System
gewonnen haben in diesem russischen
System plötzlich solch Friktionen
Auftreten von Menschen die sagen nee das
finden wir nicht richtig und das sind
nicht nur Menschen die auf der Straße
sind und sonst schon für Demokratie sehr
mutig demonstriert hat ich habe noch
nicht ganz raus gehört Herr Trittin wie
man ihn jetzt begegnen sollen also wir
sind bei der Einschätzung wozu er fähig
ist warum er welche Dinge tun wir haben
ich gar nicht eingestellt hab nur gesagt
das ist das wo er jetzt vor der Wahl
steht und wenn er die militärische
Aggression unterlässt und aufgrund
dieses Druckes und der Verzögerung dir
in der Ukraine hat an den
Verhandlungstisch zurückkehrt ist er
willkommen nur wir können nicht mit
Hoffnung darauf dass er irgendwann mit
ihm reden auf diese Dinge verzichten
fakt ist dass wir jetzt erstmal der
kriegerische Auseinandersetzung in der
Ukraine haben und fakt ist auch das der
Bundeskanzler in seiner
Regierungserklärung angekündigt hat dass
er jetzt ein Sonderfonds einrichten will
um das Militär in Deutschland wieder fit
zu machen und auch das zwei Prozent Ziel
einzuhalten
ist das nicht eine Form von Realpolitik
wo sie auch sagen müssen das ist jetzt
notwendig also erstmal muss ich sagen
das ist ja eine absolute Kehrtwende der
SPD ist also der Fraktionsvorsitzende
der SPD der Herr Mütze nicht hat der
noch ein paar Stunden vorher gesagt
bevor es diese Regierungserklärung gab
also weitere Milliarden in die Rüstung
das kommt mit ihnen nicht in Frage und
ich kann mich auch gut entsinnen als wir
hier im Bundestag zu einer Sondersitzung
zusammenkamen als Frau von der Leyen zur
EU ging und ihre Nachfolgerin berufen
wurde ist nützlich ganz entschieden
gegen das Prozent Ziel aufgetreten und
da wird sich ja etwas dabei gedacht
haben und ich glaube dass es keine gute
Idee ist jetzt zu sagen wir brauchen
mehr Geld für die Rüstung denn die der
ital der Bundeswehr hat sich in den
letzten 16 Jahren verdoppelt der ist
also 10% des Bundeshaushaltes und da
muss man sich doch mal die Frage stellen
wo ist denn das viele Geld geblieben
warum konnten sich die Rüstungskonzerne
leisten die Bundeswehr mit Material zu
beliefern was nicht funktioniert also
A400M ist ja eines der sozusagen
eklatantesten Beispiele und die Verträge
die zwischen dem Ministerium also
letztendlich zwischen uns der
öffentlichen Hand und der
Rüstungsindustrie abgeschlossen wurden
die sind alle so dass im Prinzip
überhaupt keine Konventionalstrafen drin
sind wenn die Dinger nicht funktionieren
wird trotzdem bezahlt und ich finde da
muss man auch mal sagen wer ist dafür
verantwortlich dass dieses Geld quasi
verbraten wurde ich kann noch mal
wiederholen in den letzten 16 Jahren ist
der Etat der Bundeswehr verdoppelt
worden und es kann glaube ich nicht nur
darum mehr Geld sondern man muss schauen
was ist mit dem Geld geworden wer hat
daran verdient und wer hat es verraten
das ist glaube ich unbestritten die Idee
die dahinter steckt ist aber ja glaube
ich dass man versucht ein klares Zeichen
auch zu setzen dass man nicht mehr nur
verhandeln möchte sondern auch eine
starke ein starkes militärisches
Gegengewicht setzen möchte wir haben
Eingangs der Sendung das Zitat der
Außenministerin gehört indem sie
beschrieb dass sich politisches Handeln
der Situation anpassen müsse können Sie
dem denn irgendetwas abgewinnen
natürlich muss ich politisches Handeln
immer der Situation passt anpassen das
ist doch völlig klar aber unsere auch
unsere geografische Lage in Europa
verpflichtet uns ja geradezu auch aus
eigenem Interesse zu sagen wir müssen
alles tun dass wir hier auf unserem
Territorium denn wir sind ja die die
mittendrin sind wenn es knallt uns mal
so etwas naja vielleicht vereinfachend
auszudrücken die davon zuerst betroffen
sind und darum gab es ja auch zum
Beispiel vor vielen Jahren die Proteste
gegen die Mittel richtigen Raketen weil
ja die Leute erkannt haben die Fliegen
nicht nach Washington die Fliegen
Bändern nach Berlin nach Bonn die
Fliegen auch nicht nach Madrid sondern
wir sind diejenigen die es trifft und
darum ist kann ich nur noch mal
appellieren und wiederholen unsere
wichtigste Aufgabe dass wir in das Feld
der diplomantie investieren Kathrin Frau
Lötsch hat gerade gesagt dass sie
beobachtet habe das Vertreter der
Regierungsfraktionen überrascht gewesen
sein als Bundeskanzler Scholz seine
Regierungserklärung gehalten hat wie
überrascht man sie
dann ist immer bei Regierungserklärung
selbst als Regierungsfraktion nicht über
jedes Detail informiert aber dass die
Frage sich gestellt hat wie man damit
umgeht und stimmen ja dem zu der
Beschreibung man muss sich das mal
vorstellen wir sind dabei jetzt fast so
viel Geld wenn man die siebrietzahlen
das ist ein großes
friedenswissenschaftliches Institut in
Schweden die gelten als Serie seriös
wenn man die Zahlen zugrunde legt dann
geben wir demnächst so viel Deutschland
alleine so viel aus für Rüstung wie
Russland in Dollar
wenn man jetzt Frankreich und die
anderen noch dazu nimmt nur die
europäischen Nato-Partner geben diese
europäischen Nato-Partner ungefähr
dreieinhalb Mal so viel für Rüstung aus
Russland und dann sind wir konfrontiert
mit einer Situation
wo für die Entsendung von 900 insgesamt
900 Soldatinnen und Soldaten nach
Litauen das Problem auftritt dass die
nicht genügend Winterbekleidung haben
dessen krasses Missverhältnis wenn man
sieht dass mit einem Drittel des Geldes
Russland einen großen Krieg und mehrere
kleine und einen militäreiner im
Militärintervention in Syrien fragt also
nur mal ins Verhältnis Geld und
militärischer Effekt
das ist aber alles nach dem Motto hätte
hätte Fahrradkette in der jetzigen
Situation muss man es hinbekommen dass
wenn man dieses Element wenn man sich
entscheiden man hat eine Armee dann
sollte sie auch einsatzfähig sein dass
diese Armee schnell einsatzfähig wird
und so verstehe ich diese Idee eines
solchen Sonderfonds dass diese
ausrüstungsmenge diese Defizite die es
gibt schnell behoben werden und dann
werden wir uns in der Tat darum kümmern
müssen dass dieses sozusagen
grauenvolle Beschaffungswesen was wir
haben wo offensichtlich unglaublich viel
Geld verbrannt worden ist verbrannten
verbrannt worden ist dass das geändert
wird aber es hilft uns jetzt nicht in
der aktuellen Situation wir werden noch
ganz andere haushaltsrestriktionen
bekommen wenn wir einen steigenden Kohle
Kohle ist in den letzten Jahren im Preis
verdreifacht auf dem Weltmarkt wir
werden wenn wir in Russland keine Kohle
mehr kaufen und die Hälfte unserer Kohle
kaufen wir in Russland wenn wir das
nicht mehr haben wenn wir das jetzt zu
Weltmarktpreisen kaufen müssen das wird
richtig teuer er Trittin lassen Sie uns
noch mal zu der Regierungserklärung
zurückkommen von den 100 Milliarden wird
man ja ein bisschen mehr kaufen können
als warme Winterjacken für die 900
Soldaten der Bundeskanzler auch was zu
gesagt was er davon kaufen will nämlich
unter anderem
Kampfflugzeuge bewaffnete Drohnen und
ähnliches aber das konnte man alles
schon nachlesen das steht nämlich im
Koalition und er darauf möchte ich
hinaus also sind ja außenpolitischer
Sprecher ihrer Fraktion also noch einmal
der zweitgrößten Regierungsfraktion
inwiefern waren sie überrascht
dass wir einen solchen Vorhaben es hat
mich nicht überrascht dass wir die
Überlegung auf dem Raum stehen haben
dass dieses geschieht
unter Wahrung der Schuldenbremse das
kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt nach Adam
Riese schon nicht Vorstand gar keine
politische Frage
das wird nicht funktionieren und dass
man meint ich habe nichts dagegen wenn
die CDU dem zustimmt aber sich von der
CDU in dieser Frage abhängig zu machen
das fand ich doch ein schrägen Gedanken
ich glaube jeder unsere zustimmen also
ich war ich weiß ja nicht irgendwie wer
Fernsehen wirklich die Debatte also auch
atmosphärisch verfolgen konnten aber es
war ja teilweise eine Stimmung im Saal
man dachte sehr Situation noch gar nicht
angemessen also im Jahr 2001 da war ich
noch nicht im Bundestag aber ich habe es
mir von meiner Kollegin noch mal
berichten lassen gab es ja auch sehr
erschütternde ernsthafte Debatten nach
nein eleven und sie sagte also Petra
Pause sagte mir sie wäre da wäre niemand
auf die Idee gekommen mitten in der Rede
zu jubeln und aufzuspringen also das
hatte auch ein bisschen was
gespenstisches als würde diese Gefahr in
der jetzt auch die Bevölkerung bei uns
ist und viele Menschen machen sich
Sorgen ich werde von vielen gerade
älteren angesprochen wir haben im
Luftschutzkeller gesessen wir wollen da
nicht noch mal sitzen das war auch
irgendwie völlig unangemessen und die
die sie hat nie gefragt nach der
Grundgesetzänderung da kann ich auch nur
staunen wie die muss ich sagen sind ja
Bestandteil der aprikkoalition sich die
Ampelkoalition von der Union abhängig
machen will auch diese Debatte kann man
irgendwann bei Phoenix in den
Mediatheken nachverfolgen und ich glaube
man kriegt auch bisschen was von der
Atmosphäre mit die auch für Beobachter
glaube ich wirklich fehlen besonders
und der hat es nur mit einem Satz gesagt
aber ich glaube wenn ich das Gesicht
hinter der Maske von Herrn Scholz
gesehen habe über diese Fragen wird hier
im Bundestag entschieden Herr Trittin
ich glaube unsere Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer fragen sich inwiefern wird
eigentlich so etwas abgestimmt unter den
Regierungsparteien das ist ja eine nicht
alltägliche Regierungserklärung gewesen
wir haben alle festgestellt 180 Grad
Wände in unterschiedlichen Bereichen
eine Zeitenwende im fernen wir zu etwas
abgestimmt in normalen Zeiten
so habe ich wenn ich Regierungserklärung
abgegeben habe es machen ja gelegentlich
auch Ressortminister oder Ministerin
oder wie ich das als
Fraktionsvorsitzender kannte ist es so
dass eine Regierungserklärung zwischen
den Ressorts im Wortlaut abgestimmt wird
und das auch die
Fraktionsvorsitzenden gerade der
Oppositionsfraktion am besten am Abend
vorher ein Exemplar bekommen was sie
nicht weiterleiten aber damit sie eine
Chance haben darauf zu antworten das ist
der Normalzustand nur Obst auf Deutsch
zu sagen wir leben nicht in
normalzuständen wir haben bis am Samstag
in den Abend hinein verhandelt über den
Wortlaut des entschließungsantrages wir
mussten die Frage parallel klären wie
kriegen wir in Europäischen Rat ein
Konsens hin 27 Mitgliedsstaaten für das
schärfste Sanktionspaket aller Zeiten
wie regeln wir die Frage war und was
liefern wir an Waffen an dieser Stelle
und deswegen sehe ich das dem Bundes
darüber nach dass er diese Praxis die
üblich ist in normalen Zeiten nur
normalen Zeiten nicht praktizieren
konnte wir reden über die Details der
Zeitenwende der festgestellten was wird
jetzt in Sachen Energiepartnerschaft mit
Russland passieren was glauben Sie wie
man da jetzt vorgehen muss also es gab
ja nun Äußerungen von Frau Schwesig der
Ministerpräsidentin von
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern dass sie
zumindest die Zusammenarbeit auf Eis
legen will die große Frage ist aber wie
kommt man irgendwann wieder zueinander
und ich hatte neulich auch
zufälligerweise einen Interview gehört
in dem sie sich geäußert haben zur Frage
der Sanktionen wo sie völlig zurecht
gesagt haben man muss sich natürlich die
Frage stellen wenn man eine Sanktion
erlässt wer wird davon am härtesten
getroffen wird man vielleicht selber
davon hart getroffen und darum ist es
auch so wichtig dass man sich das genau
überlegt aber die ich glaube was gerade
was die Energiefrage betrifft ist die
jetzige Situation ja auch vielleicht die
Chance dass es Innovationssprung
innerhalb der Bundesrepublik gibt und
das über die die Energiewende die ja
schon so lange ja man hatte sie sich
vorgenommen aber noch nicht umfassend
umgesetzt dass es da ein Schub gibt das
könnte sein aber trotz alledem wir leben
in einer Welt und wir müssen diesen
Krieg beenden aber trotzdem müssen wir
die Beziehungen gestalten anders geht es
nicht Innovationssprung Energiewende wir
gehen ja die Stichworte Herr Trittin was
macht diese zeitenwände jetzt mit den
Vorhaben der Ampelkoalition gerade in
Sachen Energiewende weil das wird ja
auch jetzt als ein Preis in Deutschland
haben man wird mehr Geld aufwenden
müssen so haben wir es gehört oder
wollen für das Militär was passiert mit
all ihren energiepolitischen Zielen in
der Ampel ja die müssen beschleunigt
werden aus die genau diesem Grund was
wir erleben erleben die Abhängigkeit von
fossilen Energien die Abhängigkeit von
Preissteigerung von
sage ich jetzt mal durchgehend
staatsmonopolistisch regierten Märkten
das gilt beim Öl das gilt beim Gas das
gilt bei der Kohle auch
deswegen ist die wesentliche
Voraussetzung dass wir nicht erpressbar
sind dass wir souveräner sind nicht dass
wir jetzt anfangen irgendwie überall
versuchen fossile Sachen her zu kaufen
für sehr teures Geld sondern radikal den
Importbedarf runterbringen wie bekommen
heute noch 70% unserer gesamten Energie
also alles was wir an Energie heizen
Strom Industrie Mobilität haben aus dem
Ausland wir müssen diese
Importabhängigkeit drastisch
runterfahren wir müssen deswegen die
Energiewende beschleunigen wir hatten
letzte Woche Frau kämpfert vom Deutschen
Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung
allerdings
auch gesagt etwas anderes nämlich das
ungefähr 80 Prozent der Energie aus
erneuerbaren gewonnen werden kann das
heißt man hat aber eine Lücke von 20
Prozent soweit ich informiert sollte ja
Gas eine Rolle als Brückentechnologie
einnehmen was macht man denn jetzt mit
den 20 Prozent Kohle Atomkraftwerke was
ist ihre nein ist ich kenne die Aussagen
und die Arbeiten von Frau Kämpfer sehr
gut sie geht auch an ihren Aussagen
davon aus dass sie am Ende einem 100%
erneuerbaren System ist und das wovon
sie reden ist ein Anteil den wir haben
werden von importierten Strom und von
importiertem Wasserstoff weil wir nicht
allen Wasserstoff auf der Fläche der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland erzeugen
können selbst mit großen offshore Parks
nicht und da sehe ich genau langfristig
die Chance auch der Zusammenarbeit mit
Nachbarn in Europa mit Nachbarn wieder
Ukraine aber auch mit einem Russland was
aufhört seine Nachbarn zu überfallen es
ist nicht so dass ich der Auffassung bin
wir wollen mit Russland wirtschaftlich
und politisch nichts mehr zu tun haben
das ist ein wichtiges Land mit 140
Einwohnern die kann man mit Millionen
Einwohnern die man nicht einfach
beiseite verschieben kann und deswegen
ja ich bin für eine erneuerbare
Energiepartnerschaft ob der Basis
erneuerbarer Energien mit unseren
Nachbarn und ein guter Nachbar wenn
Russland wieder ein guter Nachbar wird
sollte auch Russland sein die waren sich
jetzt einig dass man mit Russland
irgendwie weitermachen muss kann man
denn aber auch mit Putin weitermachen
ist ja eigentlich als Staatschef
reintegrierbar in die Weltpolitik
also Putin hat ja nun als Aggressor sich
erwiesen aber ich muss das noch mal
wiederholen nicht erst jetzt und
trotzdem wäre es noch mal wichtig ein
Blick darauf zu werfen wie sich die
Situation ich hatte ja die Rede
angesprochen 2001 vor dem Deutschen
Bundestag wo von den gemeinsamen Haus
Europa die Rede war darauf hatte er sich
ja noch auf gorbotschaft bezogen der ja
mit dieser Idee viele begeistert hat
damals
89,90 und ich
hoffe und ich gehe davon aus dass auch
die Menschen in Russland etwas anderes
wollen sie wollen nicht in Armut leben
sie wollen nicht im Krieg Leben und sie
wollen auch nicht für die Interessen von
wenigen Leuten ihre Kinder in einem
Krieg opfern müssen aber was heißt das
konkret wie viel Chancen geben sie denn
der russischen Opposition im Land also
was ist die Alternative zu Putin
ich glaube das ist dort wir haben es ja
auch gesehen dass verschiedene sind ja
nicht nur die Menschen auf die auf die
Straße gehen das sind ja auch die
Menschen die ihren wie auch immer
erworbenen Wohlstand gefährdet sehen es
gibt Zusammenkünfte Petitionen
Erklärung von kommunalen Vertretern und
die müssen wir auch stärken und es gibt
ja auch zum Beispiel ganz viele
Partnerschaften Städtepartnerschaften da
gibt es Leute die sagen oh die darf man
jetzt nicht mehr fortführen ich sage
ganz im Gegenteil man muss jeden
gesprächskanal auf der kommunalen Ebene
auf der Ebene der Wissenschaft das muss
man fliegen und dazu beitragen dass
solche Politik nicht akzeptiert wird von
den Menschen vor dem wie sehen Sie die
Chancen dass es zu einem Regimewechsel
zu einem
Versprechen
das weiß ich nicht aber ich bin sehr
dafür dass wir ausgehend von dem alten
Satz von Egon Bahr Amerika ist
unverzichtbar aber Russland ist
unverrückbar und auch mal angucken was
es an kulturellen Bindungen gibt und das
sehen viele Menschen und da muss auch
wissen wir haben ja ein paar
hunderttausend Menschen russischer und
übrigens ukrainischer Herkunft hier in
Deutschland die leben hier dieses zu
stärken und beizubehalten und dieses
Signal zu senden das ist wichtig wir
müssen sagen es ist putinskrieg und
nicht Russland ist unser Feind das ist
die russische Bevölkerung nicht kurze
Schlussrunde gibt es
irgendetwas
tröstendes während wir hier reden
sterben ja Menschen in der Ukraine
wofür kann keine aus diesem Leid
irgendetwas entstehen kann so etwas
entstehen wie ein erneuertes festeres
Fundament für rechten Demokratie dass
die Menschen weltweit vielleicht das
jetzt mehr zu schätzen wissen als sie
das möglicherweise vor diesem
Angriffskrieg geschätzt haben ich bin
nicht optimistisch ich glaube das Beste
was zur Zeit zu erreichen ist eine
Neubegründung jener Grundlagen für die
Sicherheit und die Zusammenarbeit in
Europa die mal von 30 40 Jahren hier
gelegt worden sind die wieder zu
installieren das wäre schon ein großer
Schritt nach vorne aber das ist keine
positive Utopie sondern glaube ich schon
fast einen verwegener Realismus weil
Leute wie viel ich sehe sehr viel
Solidarität es gab und gerade wir
sprachen ja von den vielen Menschen die
hier leben in meinem Wahlkreis in
Berlin-Lichtenberg leben sehr viele
Menschen die aus der Ukraine gekommen
sind die hier aus den Staaten der
ehemaligen Sowjetunion gekommen sind und
die sagen wir wollen hier gemeinsam in
Frieden leben und wir wollen auch den
Frieden dort unterstützen und ich glaube
dass diese Solidarität und dieses
Zusammenleben hier auch ein
Hoffnungszeichen sein kann wie lange
müssen wir auf Frieden warten in der
Ukraine dann wird das jetzt gehen dass
die Frage kann glaube ich niemand seriös
beantworten wir können nur alles dafür
tun dass die Waffen niedergelegt werden
und das ist zu einem Waffenstillstand
kommt und dann zu einer guten
Entwicklung was ich weiß es nicht es
kann Tage dauern es kann Jahre dauern
dann Frau Lötscher Trittin ganz
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Diskussion für
ihr Kommen und Ihnen zu Hause herzlichen
Dank für in Interesse an unserer Sendung
bleiben sie jetzt dran das Neueste von
diesem Tag gibt es jetzt bei unseren
Kollegen von Phoenix der Tag bleiben sie
jetzt also bei Phoenix und bleiben Sie
wie immer bleiben Sie gesund
[Musik]